I'm Mike Wells and
this is my bad interview experience.
So during an interview one time,
I was given 15 minutes to write
the computer side of tic tac toe.
A function that would
play the computer side.
Now I play tic tac toe
a lot with my kids.
And we all know, if you get
three corners, you win the game.
So that's what I approached it as, and
I'm standing at the white board and
I keep mumbling to myself just
get three corners and I win.
I'm telling the interviewer if
I get three corners, I win.
And I wasted fifteen minutes trying to
win the game of tic tac toe and, at
the end, I didn't even have a function
that would play the game of tic tac toe.
It was horrible.
It wouldn't even run.
It would have been better for
me to just write a function that would
put an X in the very
first available slot.
Instead, I'm too worried about
winning and winning and winning.
I walked away from that, and
I had a friend who interviewed at
the same company, and I was like, dude,
I had this question, and
I didn't do very well.
And he laughed about it,
and he reassured me.
He said, I bombed it as well the first
time and then we sat down and
worked through another solution
that not only played the game, but
also played it very well.
So that was fun and I get to learn
a little bit from the process as well.